I'm in our body I'm gonna break your arm  you're gonna attracting careers over I'm  gonna let him Army and then we'll see  how we defend the Lombard as a Jiu-Jitsu  practitioner as a two-stripe white belt  yeah you're gonna need some trouble down  here well that's what you think now here  my elbows are here okay and now I'm here  oh look look he's grabbing my head he's  controlling my I control posture I  opposite arm reach here I go for the  tricep foot in the hip and I'm around  here boom yeah that's this little  surprise has this little chicken wing  let's do this he's gonna arm bar  see now he's got you even when he gets  you here I bring my I bring my elbows  here my posture up here and I look to  the sky as I stand up and I pop out and  look at this look at this I call this  sliding the first  here Judo Judo Judo Judo and winner